London and speak to our reporter Aisha
zahid Aisha what do we know
well Kimberly as you said Sky News
understands that GMB will be meeting
ambulance representatives to discuss
potential further strike action they'll
be considering up to six more additional
dates of strike action when it comes to
ambulance services of course we've
already had two of those days already
and then on top of that this morning
Health unions also met with Steve
Barclay the health secretary to discuss
pay when it comes to Junior doctors
Junior doctors have casted ballots
deciding on whether or not to take
strike action the BMA the britical
medical association has 45
000 members involved in the ballot the
results are expected at the end of
February and if it does go ahead the
strike action it would be it would
entail a 72-hour walkout in March and as
well as the BMA Junior doctor members
are part of the hsca Union and the
hospital doctors Union are also in the
midst of a ballot trying to decide
whether or not they want to take part in
strike action now the talks that took
place with Steve Barclay Health
secretary have been described as
constructive and positive conversation
the health bodies say that they went in
to address the situation with the
pay-review body with pay when it comes
to Junior doctors and the situation
they're in but also to make it very
clear the state that the NHS is in and
following the meeting we had some a few
words from the hsea here's what they
said
they they were in listening mode I'm not
too sure what will happen now there has
certainly been no movement on anything
to do with pay which is obviously a
major issue for the junior doctors at
the moment and obviously our Junior
doctors have been balloted at the moment
and the VMAs will be I've also been
balloted
um there was no commitment to any extra
money any money seems to be thought to
be found from what they call efficiency
savings
of course there's always a concerning
question with about getting people
working harder potentially although they
would say not
well you heard a recap of what the
meeting entailed some optimism it being
described as a constructive positive
meeting and it all pertains to pay
levels with Junior doctors so the unions
say that Junior doctors have sustained a
real terms pay cut of 26 since
2008 to which uh BMA
chair said that 26 is a lot to lose from
your salary so though it is a lot of
money to be asking for it's a lot of
money to lose as well so as I said
ballots have been cast for junior
doctors results expected towards the end
of February if it does happen it could
mean up to 45 000 Junior doctors walking
out in March that would include walking
out from emergency care as well and in
the meantime we've potentially got six
more dates for strike action when it
comes to the ambulance services as well